members of Congress are hot on the trail
of UFO Secrets reportedly held by the
Pentagon including allegations that
alien materials are being stashed in
studied by Aerospace contractors now at
least one prominent defense contractor
is letting it be known that it is
actively seeking government contracts
that might involve UFO technology George
Knapp has our exclusive story
[Music]
tucked somewhere in the vast Nellis Air
Force complex a private defense
contractor is working on weapons Tech
that may or may not ever see the light
of day that same contractor has an
office inside Wright-Patterson Air Base
home to the military's original UFO
investigations with 20 offices in 17
States Radiance Technologies has quietly
become a major player in developing
Cutting Edge weapons and systems for the
Pentagon but unlike some of its larger
competitors Radiance doesn't shy away
from a topic long considered Fringe or
forbidden UFOs if somebody had a UFO and
wanted to take it apart to figure out
how it worked you'd accept that content
oh sure yeah absolutely why not all
right
I'm waiting for one of those Yeah Tim
Tinsley is an engineer who spent two
decades working on missile defense
systems before he joined Radiance unlike
Behemoth such as Lockheed or Northrop
Radiance is entirely owned by its
employees Tinsley Rose to become
president of the company which has its
home base in Huntsville Alabama also
known as Rocket City whether in Las
Vegas and San Antonio Dayton Ohio or or
Huntsville it doesn't matter you know
the idea there is we have a core set of
values that runs through the the company
so we have a hundred and five thousand
square feet facility here so it's a you
know made up of Laboratories classified
and unclassified but what exactly does
Radiance do there are hints on its
website of exotic defense Technologies
such as Star Wars like direct energy
weapons Hypersonic missiles systems to
defend against cyber warfare and who
knows what else
what are they doing at Nellis Air Force
Base I can't tell you a lot right but
what I can tell you is that we've
supported the Las Vegas Community Nellis
Air Force Base for over 20 years and you
know a lot of the work we do is mostly
for the air force of course but it
resides in uh that rdt and E the
research development test and evaluation
Spectrum as Tinsley knows Nellis is one
of the places rumored to house
mysterious materials of Unknown Origin
the story first reported by us more than
three decades ago is that a super secret
program housed in or near Nevada's Area
51 military base has been trying to
reverse engineer alien technology that
story spread all over the world what has
been dismissed as mere folklore by
military agencies and defense
contractors now however Congress is
nosing around key committees have
received closed-door briefings alleging
the rumors are true and legislation is
pending to incur whistleblowers to step
forward and tell what they know about
crashed saucers Radiance isn't able to
confirm the allegations but the company
has positioned itself just in case
months ago it announced the hiring of a
reverse engineering specialist long-time
Navy intelligence official Jay Stratton
formerly the head of the pentagon's UAP
or UFO task force Stratton urged
Radiance to hire Dr Travis Taylor who
worked with Stratton as the chief
scientist for the UAP task force when
Radiance announced the hiring of the two
Veterans of UFO research its news
releases pointedly mentioned their UFO
credentials not worried about a crazy
perception of you as a company that is
reverse engineering UFOs or something uh
no no we provide customer Solutions so
whatever our customers want us to to
work on and support them that's what
we'll do
astrophysicist Travis Taylor won't say
what he and Stratton are working on but
made it clear what they hope to tackle
Jay and I are working on growing the
capabilities of doing reverse
engineering of of foreign materials and
so on and so it makes it the perfect
place if we were to get something to
reverse engineer we would absolutely
want to do that George Knapp 8 News Now